welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i'm the
host of the show but
today i am going to be joined by a
special temporary guest co-host his name
is greg knuckles greg thanks for joining
me thanks for having me on how are you
doing today doing well how are you i am
doing great uh the weather's been warm
lately we're getting those first like
nice sunny days of the spring which is
always great to see
we've got a lot planned for the show
today it's going to be a great show if i
were to guess
but before we get into that a couple
reminders
if you like the show and you'd like to
support it of course you could like rate
and subscribe wherever you happen to get
podcasts
if you want to support the show in a
more financial way you could use our
discount code
it's sbs pod you can use that at
bulksupplements.com
and get a 5 percent discount off of your
order you could also potentially
subscribe to the mass research review
which we both co-author or you could
download macro factor
that is the diet app that we
played a part in creating along with a
really talented team
of very smart people so it's a great
nutrition app you can try it out with a
free trial see if you like it and if you
love it stick around
uh okay so moving on road to the stage
how are things going
uh things are going well and they have
been going well for quite a while so
this is my
uh ever so slightly preemptive one-year
retrospective
macro factor launched in october
or september late september
but the internal alpha build dropped in
february so i have now been using it for
364 days tomorrow will be
the one year anniversary which will have
already passed by the time this episode
comes out um
and so over the past year where i've
been
in a somewhat dedicated fashion focusing
on my diet and nutrition more
i'm down slightly in excess of 35 pounds
which i'm pretty stoked about um
and i'm feeling
i'm feeling
truly and robustly in control of my
weight
for the first time
probably in my adult life uh probably
the first time since high school uh
heist in high school it was much easier
to manage because i had so few demands
on my time that uh you know if i wanted
to
lose 15 pounds between football and
basketball season like whatever i would
just be on the court for 10 hours a day
and just melt the weight off but i i
don't have 10 hours a day to be on the
court anymore which is very unfortunate
um
so yeah it's it's awesome um and i think
one of the things that has helped me the
most is that
i
i rarely do anything super strictly and
the same thing applies to my nutrition
um
and
i think one of the things that macro
factor has helped me with is that
there's no true failure condition um
like as long as you keep tracking
uh accurately and realistically then you
know if you just don't want to give a
[ __ ] about your diet for a week or
something like that's fine like just go
go and do whatever you want but then you
still have the data there to give you
good
uh good recommendations to kind of get
back on track
in a
in a way that takes a lot of stress out
of it like there's
like i don't have to worry about what do
i need to do to get back on track like
the numbers are there i know exactly
what i need to do um
and so yeah it's it's been great it's uh
made the process so much easier than
previous attempts to lose weight and
it's taken so much guesswork out of it
um so yeah it will be a year tomorrow
and it's been a good year
awesome that's good stuff
um all right so
last episode uh i ended with a
cliffhanger ending and i mentioned that
i would be
talking a little bit about diet
recomposition i got some feedback the
people do not like cliffhanger endings
so that will not be a staple of the show
but anyway i wanted to make sure i
covered this first so that it didn't
find itself on the cutting room floor
yet again i wanted to make sure i got it
in this episode
so it's a little coach's corner segment
about how to set up a diet for
recomposition so if you're not familiar
with the
the term body recomposition the end the
general idea with recomping is that
you are building muscle and losing fat
at the same time
so um this is somewhat related to the
concept of main gaining which has become
uh
more popular in the youtube space lately
uh you might also call it gaintaining
that that would be i think a synonymous
way to phrase it but the idea with those
terms is that you're keeping body fat
percentage relatively stable as you're
gaining muscle and gaining weight along
the way
so the basic principle is kind of the
same you want to be making body
composition progress without taking the
kind of what's become the standard
cyclical approach of i'm going to do a
focused bulking
phase and then a focused cutting phase
it's kind of
doing both of those things
simultaneously to an extent
now
you might hear that idea of body
recomposition and say wait a minute
i know for a fact that that is
impossible and something that should not
be attempted you know you have to either
bulk or cut there is no middle ground um
and
the reality is it's not nearly as rare
as some people would suggest like
uh is it the
most efficient way to approach muscle
growth probably not just if we're
looking at pure muscle growth over time
is it the most efficient way to lose fat
again maybe not if if you're defining
efficiency as the most amount of weight
loss or weight loss or fat loss in a
given unit of time then the more extreme
you go the more efficient theoretically
but what's nice about this is there is
efficiency in the long run so if you're
able to do a muscle building phase where
you're not
uh gaining what you perceive to be an
excessive amount of fat that then has to
be cut in a later phase there is some
inherent efficiency in trying to make
incremental prof progress in both
directions simultaneously and like i
said a lot of people have suggested that
this is a super rare thing that is only
feasible for a very small percentage of
the population
i think that
empirical evidence is chipping away at
that idea so
there was recently a review paper by uh
chris barakat and colleagues
and i thought it was a fantastic review
paper i'm gonna link it in the show
notes but one of their main observations
is this idea that recomposition is super
rare
is not compatible with the literature in
fact recomposition is observed quite
frequently in the literature and in some
cases even in groups where you wouldn't
maybe expect it to be a feasible outcome
so i'm going to get into
who
is most likely to achieve recomposition
and who is least likely i'm going to get
into that in a minute but first i want
to at least deal with two questions that
seem similar but are a little bit
different so
i'm going to talk about recom recomping
as a specific goal in and of itself
but it i should acknowledge that
sometimes
recomposition happens along the way to a
different goal so what i mean by that is
uh sometimes people will be cutting and
they'll say well how do i maximize the
accretion or the retention of lean mass
during my cut now the goal there is not
strictly recomposition it's
my goal is fat loss here but
how can i kind of hedge my bets to
either
retain or hopefully gain some lean mass
along the way so the best way to do that
is just follow best practices for weight
loss plenty of protein small to moderate
deficit things like that so
i wanted to acknowledge that there are
some cases where you might be cutting
but say hey how can i maybe
open the door potentially to a little
bit of recomposition so that's how you
would do that another way to look at
this is sometimes people will say hey
i'm bulking
the specific goal is i am bulking up
here gaining lean mass but along the way
how do i minimize fat gain you know even
at a given level of caloric intake as
we've talked about before a high protein
approach might be a way that you can
minimize some of that uh unwanted fat
gain just because it gives you a little
more flexibility in terms of the thermic
effect of feeding there's usually a
an effect by which high protein
increases satiety so you're less likely
to go well above your caloric target
just because the protein is making you
full uh so there there are uh argan
arguments to be made that a
a bulk with low protein at 4 000
calories is going to lead to potentially
more fat gain than a bulk with really
high protein at 4 000 calories so i
wanted to acknowledge that those are
slightly different questions that are
not the focus of this segment the focus
of this segment is
i want to recomp like that is my
explicit goal i'm not just trying to
save muscle during a cut or something
like that so the first set of questions
is first of all
when is this actually likely like who is
going to successfully recomp uh there
are a number of characteristics that may
make recomping more feasible for a given
individual so first of all if you're
brand new to training you are absolutely
primed for recomping uh you have so much
ability to gain lean mass that you can
do it in less than favorable or less
than optimal scenarios such as a caloric
deficit as long as it's not an enormous
caloric deficit yeah
you don't even have to go that far i
mean like one one of the
pretty consistent observations in
uh in the literature just looking at
like lifestyle interventions to get
people more active is if you take
someone who's completely untrained and
very sedentary and just have them like
walk more often or do like 30 minutes on
the treadmill three times a week
they very often
uh gain like a non-trivial amount of
lean mass in their lower body and drop
maybe like half a kilo of fat or
something so
if you're
untrained enough
you can recomp just from walking like
it's it's not
yeah
it's the whole point of the segment it's
not something that's just like
completely
unknown to science like it under this
the circumstance you're talking about
someone who's completely untrained it
doesn't even take that much stimulus at
all to accrete some lean mass
right and that was something that was
noticed in i recently talked about that
meta analysis by james steele and
colleagues about like interval training
versus
um
continuous study-state training and in
both cases uh an accretion of lean mass
was observed and that was because they
were looking mostly at untrained people
and like you said if you take an
untrained person and say hey why don't
you jog a few times a week they're
probably going to gain some lean mass in
a lot of cases
so if you're
brand new to training or if you're
coming off of an extended layoff
so if you had been highly trained and
you've been out of the gym because of a
coveted lockdown you've been out of the
gym because of an injury and not doing
other stuff at home to kind of maintain
muscle
again you're going to be primed for
muscle growth
and recomping would be very feasible
if you're making a very substantial
change to your diet or your training so
like for example i started training
really hard at the age of 12.
uh could i have recompt at the age of 18
when i started training like
uh a more informed lifter absolutely
because like
you could be six years trained at the
age of 18 but but if you've been
following really silly programs making a
substantial improvement to your training
approach could open the door to
recomposition because you should be
tapping in to a really different
stratosphere of gains once you figure
out how to how to improve your training
if you have plenty of room to grow
before you reach your genetic limit of
muscularity wherever that may be uh then
then recomping might be feasible if you
have plenty of body fat to lose like you
know if when we did our um
participant level meta analysis on in
the whole p ratio debate what we found
was you know any semblance of recomping
or even just gaining lean mass without
fat mass gain accompanying it
very feasible unless
you start getting down into that you
know six seven eight percent body fat
range so if you're super lean recomping
is going to be a hard thing to do but if
you've got some body fat to lose it
might be quite feasible and then of
course if you are making pharmacological
changes that alter your state of
anabolic potential
then certainly a lot of things can
happen including recomposition now when
is it unlikely that's purely the inverse
if you're extremely advanced and you're
near your genetic muscular limit and
you're continuing your normal training
and diet practices and you're very lean
like those are all things that would
make
recomping less feasible or at least
would shrink the potential magnitude of
recomposition you have less to work with
there and of course if you're in a large
deficit that can make it uh very
challenging as well to it at a certain
point being in a huge caloric deficit is
going to make it very difficult to be
gaining lean mass as you're losing that
fat mass so
that kind of covers who it's for who
might be able to attain this like i said
it's been observed in the literature
many many many times it is not a rare
thing
but one of the things i'm noticing is
increasingly people are suggesting that
you have to have super super high
protein in order to successfully recomp
and like i said if if you are going to
be bulking at a fixed number of calories
and saying will i have a leaner bulk
with 300 grams of protein a day instead
of 75 the answer is yes now is it
how much does that matter is it
meaningful which diet is more enjoyable
those are all up for debate but
um
the idea that you necessarily must have
a super high protein approach
i just simply haven't seen convincing
evidence to support the claim now i have
seen one uh piece of evidence that is
often cited um and i simply disagree
with the conclusion uh respectfully so
one of the places i i see people making
this claim or the the place people are
citing
does go back to that review paper by uh
chris barakat and colleagues and like i
said i thought it was a terrific paper
and i have a tremendous amount of
respect for everybody involved with it i
mean it was uh chris barakat jeremy
pearson guillermo escalante
bill campbell eduardo de souza i mean
these are terrific researchers so i
don't want it to sound like i'm being uh
critical
but a lot of times people point to that
study and say see you need to go above
your normal protein intake if you want
to do recomp
now
i consider kind of the standard protein
range for lifters
everybody knows the range right 1.6 to
2.2 grams of protein per kilogram of
body mass per day that's kind of the
standard recommendation now if you look
in that paper by bearacat and colleagues
there's a table i believe it was table
three where it's looking at instances of
recomposition and people who are fairly
well trained and lifting weights and
things like that
now one of the
fascinating things is that like if you
look at that table
which is probably the most relevant
table for most of our listeners and
readers
uh
it's really hard to look at the data
summarize there and say oh yeah you need
to go from high protein to extra high
protein when you're recomping
one of the things that will jump out to
you if you look into it is
most of the studies in the table
they are comparing two different groups
within each study that are eating the
same amount of protein uh and in most
cases everyone in every study is eating
plenty we're talking about 1.6 grams per
kilogram or higher so there's not even a
lot of studies that have the possibility
of making that argument within this
summary table like if you're not
comparing low versus high protein it's
going to be very difficult to say this
is really solid evidence that you need
to go super high with your protein now
there was one exception it was a study
by campbell and colleagues that really
was looking at a discrepancy in protein
intakes between one group and the other
but if you look closely at the data
you know what what they what they
summarized in the table was
both groups increase fat free mass but
only the high protein group lost a
significant amount of fat mass if you
look more closely at it what you see is
the the high protein group gained 2.1
kilograms of fat free mass versus only
0.6 in the low protein group
so to me understanding how protein works
one group was eating sufficient protein
the other was eating insufficient
protein just based on the normal
1.6 to 2.2
range that we typically used
so that's not surprising that that's a
very straightforward finding you know
get into the optimal protein range and
you're going to be happier with your fat
free mass gains now the the part that
caught me was only the high protein
group lost a significant amount of fat
mass
which would kind of lean into this idea
that when you go higher with proteins
some kind of magic's going on with
recomposition
if you look at it the high protein group
lost 1.1 kilograms of fat mass the low
protein group lost 0.8 that's a two very
similar numbers especially when you
consider body composition was measured
using a mode ultrasound which is a
really nice piece of equipment
the portability the affordability the
convenience it's a very nice tool
but
i'm not going to get too excited about a
discrepancy of 300 grams when we're
talking about a mode ultrasound it's
just simply not that precise so there's
really only one study there where you
would look at it and say okay maybe
there is more benefit to recomping at
higher versus lower but it's just kind
of putting us into the range that we
already recommend whether you're cutting
or bulking anyway and there's really no
direct evidence to suggest that going
beyond that is necessarily helpful aside
from just the very straightforward facts
we talked about i think it was last
episode or the one before we talked
about the protein over feeding research
like the studies by antonio and
colleagues and things like that
very straightforward stuff if you're on
a super high protein diet it's going to
be satiating you're going to have a high
thermic effect of feeding that might
attenuate fat fat gain to some extent
because a very straightforward
mechanisms um
uh but but you could achieve the same
thing by making different food choices
and different macro choices like there's
nothing magic about it it's just about
managing your caloric intake and your
caloric surplus
and then of course
if you're going from insufficient
protein to sufficient uh of course
that's going to increase your ability to
uh to gain fat free mass but we have no
direct evidence that says when you're
recomping you need to go beyond and
above
the uh the typical range of 1.6 to 2.2
grams per kilogram so
my opinion how do you set up a diet for
recomping uh you have three options when
it comes to just pure weight change
right so
you could aim for no weight change at
all stay totally weight stable
or you could argue that maybe it would
be appropriate depending on your
situation to aim for a modest magnitude
of weight loss or a very modest
magnitude of weight gain i think the
classical approach is to do this in a
manner that is weight stable where
weight is not changing significantly but
theoretically you might be able to see a
little upward or downward trend and
still call it recomposition but what you
don't want to do
is do a really aggressive cut or really
aggressive bulk and try to
basically pray for this idea that you're
going to have substantial recomposition
and i think it's also worth noting that
if you're not going for the weight
neutral approach if you're trying to
either gain or lose weight recomposition
is probably going to be much more likely
with a slow rate of weight loss than a
slow rate of weight gain
just purely based on how the math works
out
fat is something like five times as
energy dense as muscle is
and so
um
you know if you are weight stable you
lose a pound of fat you gain a pound of
muscle your weight stable but you are
still in a calorie deficit just because
that pound of fat represented
so
so much more energy that was being
expended
and generally it's not
it's not that hard to gain maybe a
little bit of muscle while you're losing
maybe a little more fat so you know if
you drop
two kilos of fat gain one kilo of muscle
uh you've lost weight that's that's a
pretty feasible thing uh but on the flip
side to recomp while gaining weight
that implies that you're gaining quite a
bit of muscle quite quickly while also
probably still being in a small calorie
deficit yeah um
so you know if you
uh if you did put on like three kilos of
muscle and lose a kilo of fat that may
be very feasible for a completely
untrained lifter a d trained lifter
getting back into it but if you're if
you're reasonably well trained
it's gonna take you a long time to put
on those three kilos of muscle um
and like
who knows maybe maybe you lose a kilo of
fat in the process but that that's going
to be a very very prolonged process to
pull that off and you're going to need
to be
really quite precise with virtually
everything you're doing so of these
options uh a modest rate of weight loss
or being roughly weight neutral i think
are probably more
generally feasible
uh situations for recomping versus a
modest rate of weight gain like it is
theoretically possible if you're gaining
weight it's just quite a bit less likely
yeah the theory suggests it can be done
but practically speaking it's it's quite
a long shot and you need a lot of things
to line up in your favor
um so when it comes to the priorities
for setting up a diet for recomping what
you want to make sure is first of all
looking at total energy intake it's got
to be low enough
to be compatible with a modest rate of
fat loss but
caloric intake cannot be so low as to
dramatically blunt hypertrophy and there
was a recent meta-analysis by murphy and
colleagues where they looked at how a
certain magnitude of energy deficit
impacts hypertrophy potential and what
they found was that as the energy
deficit grew by a hundred calories a day
the effect size for gains and lean mass
did drop
by about
0.03 units now that's practically
not very easy to kind of digest but i
think that the key takeaway there is
as the deficit got bigger
lean mass gains became more challenging
and as the deficit got up to about 500
calories per day that was where the
regression line predicted a full uh
essentially a full attenuation of gains
in lean mass now i'm not saying that
that is a
generalizable theoretical truth and that
no one can gain lean mass in a 500
calorie per day deficit but that's where
the data indicated as you're getting up
near 500 calories a day for your deficit
it's going to be pretty tough sledding
so i think that's helpful in kind of
dictating the
ideal deficit to shoot for and as an
extension of that kind of what kind of
rate of weight loss you can potentially
be aiming for you know as you extend
that information out
the other thing you want to focus on so
calorie intake has to be low enough to
support some fat loss but high enough to
support uh gains in lean mass you also
need to make sure that your protein is
high enough to support gaining muscle so
in most cases based on the evidence i'm
seeing 1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram of
body mass
still seems to be a good range there
nothing wrong with going higher but
there are obviously trade-offs as
protein gets higher it starts displacing
other macro nutrients it starts limiting
food choices to some extent it can make
you so full that it's kind of
challenging to maintain a diet in some
cases so 1.6 to 2.2 should be fine in
many cases but
since that's scaled to total body mass
it can really fall apart when you get to
extreme ends of body composition ranges
just based on normative data so uh you
know because that ultimately that range
was calculated based on the typical body
comp of the typical study participant uh
so pretty much
a large portion of it is college-aged
folks and say hey you want to come do a
study and make 75 bucks like that's
pretty much where that that number is
coming from yeah so if you're
really really lean um you know
or or you're on the higher end of the
body fat spectrum those numbers might
not work out as well in that case i'd
say probably somewhere between 2 and
2.75 grams per kilogram of fat free mass
just making your best estimate that
should put you in a pretty similar range
you can make an evidence-based argument
that there are some circumstances
where in order for recomping to be
feasible you should bump that up to 2.3
to 3.1 grams per kilogram of fat free
mass but from the data i've seen the
only situation where that really applies
is if you're quite lean or dieting very
hard and you're just trying to hang on
to some hope of retaining or potentially
gaining fat free mass in the process but
that scenario alone is automatically a
bit of a long shot for recomposition so
my recomposition guideline like i said
1.6 to 2.2 grams per kilogram of total
mass or 2 to 2.75 grams per kilogram of
fat free mass if you're in a
physiological state where recomping is
feasible
those guidelines should make it happen
if you're in a state where body body
recomposition is not feasible for you
then it ain't gonna work uh and so
that's the reality of the situation but
i think uh getting back to the
perception of the feasibility of
recomping i think it is a goal that is
accessible to more people than the
average lifter might think
makes sense to me
all right so moving on greg i understand
that you have a research review
about a topic that i'm sure uh will
excite many many of our listeners yeah
yeah so this is a little research review
about french fries uh but it's actually
more than anything just kind of an
object lesson in
not taking
nutritional epidemiology too literally
uh sometimes so uh
yeah so i i don't plan on digging super
far into this paper um mostly just using
it to to make a point so anyway uh hot
off the presses title of the paper is
french fried potato consumption and
energy balance a randomized control
trial by smith and colleagues recently
published in the american journal of
clinical nutrition uh
and so this is a delightful study i
don't know why but i
i enjoy rcts where they're just feeding
people individual foods and seeing what
happens uh one of my favorite studies of
all time i refer to it as the muffin
study uh because it's one of the only
rcts i'm aware of where the
actual experimental manipulation being
done was just feeding people muffins um
so i i'm already off track uh but
whatever we're just gonna roll with it
in that study um
they they basically fed people the same
muffins one group was fed a muffin
where
the uh the fats used to make the muffin
uh all came in the form of saturated
fats the other group uh all of the fats
and the muffins were polyunsaturated
fats and uh
basically over over the course of the
study like there wasn't a training
intervention or anything like that it's
basically just we're going to feed you
these muffins and
we're going to feed you these muffins as
a
mechanism of manipulating your daily
fatty acid intake whether saturated or
polyunsaturated and then just look to
see
what effects that has on body comp
metabolic markers etc
and if memory serves in that study the
saturated fat uh
muffin group um
gained a non-trivial amount of fat
really nothing much happened to lean
mass and the polyunsaturated group uh
actually gained a non-trivial amount of
lean mass without much going on in the
way of fat
just purely from an overfeeding
intervention and so on i just find that
delightful you know you recruit a bunch
of subjects you say like hey we're going
to pay you to eat muffins for a few
months
will you come to the lab and eat muffins
from time to time like i think that's
incredible uh but then two
when it came out it was kind of at the
peak of
i think just kind of like the general
backlash to
the
the fda's guidelines around
saturated fat consumption and like does
that cause heart disease or whatnot like
that was when there was a lot of energy
in the oh actually all of this is wrong
eat as much saturated fat as you want
it's totally fine it was like at the
peak of
that
discourse and so when that paper dropped
there were a lot of people who were very
upset about it yeah and that made it uh
even more fun to me so anyway you know
they're i think we have past the peak
where there is major backlash saying hey
stop being mean to saturated fats
but
we are at a new peak where the uh
just
enthusiastic terror and fear associated
with
polyunsaturated fats is through the roof
so
we're changing one peak for the other
but i'm sure people would be
just as upset if that paper came out
today
that is probably true actually
i have a question for you and if you
don't know the answer i have a question
for the audience okay so what's the deal
with seed oils like so i i i mean i know
what they are but i do remember
maybe 10 years ago
everyone was up in arms about seed oils
and omega-6s specifically
and then like that basically seemed to
die down quite a bit and then in my last
uh
uh instagram story
q a session i got like a half dozen
questions about
seed oils what do
like are they going to kill me fast or
kill me slow um
and it seemed to have come out of
nowhere i haven't
really seen that discourse percolating
and then all of a sudden it's just i do
a q a and a bunch of people have
questions about that so it has there
been a new like major piece of media
released about seed oils that might be
um
motivating that that line of questioning
i don't think so i i think it has just
kind of
um
that interest has kind of formed in
parallel with the increased interest in
carnivore diets
and people have said like okay all i eat
is steak now what are the multifaceted
uh avenues i can approach to make this
sound really cool and good
and i think one of the areas people have
circled in on is like well at least i'm
not eating seed oils anymore yeah um but
the only
uh stuff i've seen about it has just
said like hey listen oxidation is bad
and you know you should only eat steak
that's about as far as i like i'm not
deep into the research on it but
i have looked at
all the research that would kind of poke
and prod at the theoretical outcomes
that would be observed if all this
mechanistic speculation were true and
relevant
and it looks like seed oils are
completely fine if you look at any like
meaning clinically meaningful outcome
yeah so that's kind of why i haven't dug
too deep into the mechanistic arguments
is cause like
if something is that scary and poisonous
and toxic and bad like
it shouldn't be that hard to find
clinically relevant evidence yeah yeah
yeah that was
that was my assumption i haven't really
looked into that research because i
don't care um
so anyway it seems that you are not
aware of like any new discrete like
major piece of media that's really put
that on people's radar so listeners if
if there's something we don't know about
the kind of
uh
a paradigm shifting thing that has
re-lodged this in the public
consciousness let me know i'm genuinely
curious because it really did just seem
to come out of nowhere
um all right now getting back to french
fries
after that
very very long diversion so um like i
said i mostly wanted to talk about this
study as an object lesson
related to
how literally maybe we should take uh
findings from nutritional epidemiology
so this was an rct a randomized control
trial so you have multiple groups people
are randomized to groups and the
theoretically the only difference in
intervention between groups is just what
they're being fed so you know variables
are being controlled this is the type of
uh the type of research one would use to
make causal inferences uh if there were
strong causal inferences to be made
so anyway this study had 180
participants took place over 30 days
there were three groups all three groups
were
uh prescribed calorie matched
nutritional interventions per day so
one group consumed 300 calories of
almonds per day one group consumed
300 calories of just plain french fries
per day and one group uh consumed 300
calories of french fries with herbs and
spices per day um and that was it like
basically told people hey go about your
life but you need to eat either these
almonds or these french fries
and so they did that for a month and
then basically they just came back in uh
put them through a battery of tests to
to look at markers of metabolic health
assessed weight assess body comp
and
i mean you can read this paper for
yourself but the conclusion from the
abstract sums it up pretty well
there were no significant differences in
fat mass or in glucoregulatory
biomarkers after 30 days of
potato consumption versus almonds
results do not suggest a causal
relationship between increased french
fried potato consumption and the
negative health outcomes studied so the
reason this is relevant is the framing
of this study
was basically just like hey if you look
at nutritional epidemiology it seems
like people who consume both a lot of
potatoes generally but then specifically
fried potato products which
fried potato products you're talking
about
french fries and potato chips that's
about it
like that tends to be associated with
negative cardio metabolic health
outcomes and uh increased body weight
increased fat mass increased
rates of obesity
and basically the inverse of all of that
i just said is true of almonds
almond consumption on a population level
seems to be associated with uh improved
cardio metabolic health outcomes uh
lower body weight uh lower rates of
obesity etc um
and this is one of those things that
isn't just like a one-off finding like
you you will see
those associations with both almonds and
fried potato products pop up
not infrequently in the nutritional
epidemiological research um
but you know
from that data you're looking at
association so you can't draw causal
inferences so that's the value of an rct
like this one
like hey based on
based on associations seems like maybe
potatoes bad almonds good let's actually
test it in our ct to see if that is the
case and it didn't really pan out and so
like i said i mostly wanted to talk
about this as kind of an object lesson
for
maybe why you shouldn't
worry
all that much about nutritional
epidemiological findings um or at least
take them super literally all the time
and i think that's especially true
as it relates to individual foods so
you know
i i feel like twice per year uh we'll
just see a spate of headlines from new
york times washington post like just a
bunch of legacy media saying like oh new
study came out turns out people who eat
chocolate uh live longer or people who
drink red wine have lower rates of
cancer or whatever um and it's just all
based on epidemiological findings and
people just take it and run with it and
and not always but often present it as
if it's a causal relationship like there
will be recommendations to readers at
the end of the article and be like you
know what don't go crazy on the
chocolate but like eat a little dark
chocolate a day like that's going to
make you healthier
and that type of advice
even if you're
interpreting the study as non-causal
evidence
if you are giving that advice to readers
you're functionally interpreting it as
causal because you're saying if you do
this thing you will get this outcome
like that's that's a causal chain uh so
even if you actually talk about the
study itself appropriately if that's the
outcome of your advice that's flowing
from it you're interpreting it as if
it's causal um
and then that type of research can also
have a tendency to confuse people
because oftentimes you can find very
very conflicting results like there was
there was a good article i think in 538
about this maybe two or three years ago
where they took
uh
like a dozen different foods and they
just
looked to see every time that they had
been shown to be associated with changes
in cancer risk
or differences in cancer risk within the
research and just just plotted all of
the individual studies from nutritional
epidemiological research and it's
basically like oh hey if you look at red
wine it's either going to cut your
cancer risk by 80 or increase it by 30
percent we have these range of findings
and like theoretically that's why
meta-analyses exist but
you know for individual consumers uh
it's it's not hard it's easy to remember
headlines and like maybe you saw a
headline that said oh hey guess what
wine gives you cancer then a year later
you see a headline that says guess what
wine protects you against cancer and
like it can be very confusing and more
to the point you can't use that research
to draw causal inferences you do need
rcts for that um
and i just feel like this study was a
nice little
object lesson and one of the reasons
why it is iffy to draw causal inferences
from epidemiological research like that
is
moving a layer deeper
than
the issues associated with
interpreting associations causally
there's also
um
so so generally in a study like that
what you're gonna do
is you're going to
find what what differs within the
population but then you know you know
that that one thing that you're looking
at isn't
isn't in and of itself
causing the divergences and health
outcomes you see so then what you try to
do is you build a model where you
co-vary for
other relevant characteristics that
might also
influence the health outcome you're
interested in so for example if you look
at french fry consumption and
uh
cancer or whatever um and you see that
like hey people who consume a lot of
french fries also tend to smoke more
like okay well we do now we need to
co-vary for smoking status to make sure
that we aren't saying like oh hey french
fries are bad uh but really it's it's
just that a lot of smokers eat french
fries and like that's why the date is
shaking out the way it is so you you
identify those things you co-vary for
all of the things that you think might
also be independently influencing the
outcome apart from just the variable of
interest
but that is
far from a perfect science
and um
even if it could theoretically work if
you had all of the data about all of the
individuals in that study like you know
if you didn't have a hundred data points
per person but you had a a million data
points per person to to literally
adjust for every
conceivable difference who knows maybe
theoretically then then things would
shake out better but that's just simply
not the data we're working with you know
you have
for a really robust epidemiological data
set maybe a hundred variables per person
and that's not going to fully
encapsulate
everything about all of those people's
lives and so specific to
uh
to this study
you think about almonds well what do you
think about well one um and you like i
didn't even think of this but you
brought it up before we started
recording if you look at the marketing
around almonds uh
you know they're they're
pretty explicitly at least in america
marketed as a health food almost a super
food yeah yeah
and so you know then you have to ask
yourself like well is that going to cor
is that going to correlate with
different behaviors so when people start
eating more almonds are they maybe doing
so because they're trying to adopt
a lot of just generally healthy
lifestyle habits one of which happens to
be eating almonds and maybe they lose
weight and maybe the almonds didn't have
a goddamn thing to do about it because
you know they were doing a dozen other
things that may have been contributing
to that outcome um
another thing about almonds they're kind
of expensive like
they're not as expensive as like walnuts
or pecans but like nuts are reasonably
expensive and
even almonds being one of the cheaper
nuts like they're still more expensive
than
a lot of foods that you could be buying
and so almond consumption is probably
also going to be associated with
socioeconomic status which like
even if you do adjust for it in analyses
like there are probably
still
other kind of like latent behaviors or
characteristics that you're not
quantifying that maybe you should also
adjust for but you can't adjust for
because it's not in the data set and so
like you know ultimately are you
picking up the independent effects of
almonds or are almonds just kind of a
stand-in for a cluster of related
variables that are ultimately driving
the differences you're seeing on a
population level that's what i what i
tend to believe is going on there um
so anyway yeah
uh
i i'm not talking about this study to
recommend that you eat a bunch of
almonds i'm not talking about this study
to recommend that you eat a bunch of
french fries talking about this study to
recommend
that the next time you see a bunch of
breathless headlines saying
you know x is associated with y uh like
x food is associated with y
health outcome on a population level
look to see if there are any rcts ask
yourself some probing questions like hey
what other behaviors or characteristics
might be associated with consumption of
this food item like
do i think that this food item is
actually playing a causal role here um
and yeah just
just don't take that stuff quite as
literally uh until it is actually
confirmed by our cts
man i have so much to say
and
i will certainly miss about half of
those things because i always take notes
say as much as you want uh we need to
record two episodes this week so if
anything on this outline can get pushed
to the next one i'm not going to be
upset about it yeah but don't say what
got pushed because that's another
cliffhanger
my hate mail folder is closed
um
you know it's funny you mentioned the
cost um for some reason this is like a
memory that's like burned into my brain
you know growing up as a kid i would
always like
have a just a tiny bit of like
internalized guilt
if i
did things that were expensive like to
my parents and it's not not at all
because they
prompted that in any way like i just for
for some reason was born with this
knowledge like
dude you are like really costing
resources here so like tread lightly and
don't like you know
spend your parents like
you know don't burn through their
retirement account just being wasteful
the first time i ever bought nuts as an
independent adult i was like horrified
like i was like oh i like almonds i'll
go check those out
and i saw the cost at the supermarket
and i immediately was like dude i think
i owe my parents like ten thousand
dollars because i ate a lot of nuts
growing up so yeah the cost component is
like uh something that shouldn't be
overlooked and like you said with
something like almonds because they're
so explicitly marketed as a healthful
snack option
i wouldn't be shocked to see just from
that one example you know someone who
abruptly increases their intake of
almonds also is revisiting their
sleeping pattern and also is exercising
more regularly and also is trying some
more stress management techniques like a
whole cluster of healthy decisions that
goes along with that behavior change
but but more to the point of
uh
epidemiology you know i've been involved
in epidemiology research projects and i
i don't want it to seem like we're
saying oh
epidemiology is is weak science just let
that go in one ear and out the other it
serves a really important purpose and
all types of research do but what's
really important is that when we see the
headline you gotta unfortunately reward
them with the clicks yeah it sucks but
you gotta at least take a look and say
was this in a petri dish was it in a
mouse was it in a fruit fly was it in a
huge you know collection of surveys was
this a randomized controlled trial you
got to get an idea of what kind of
research it was that they're reacting to
and then you have to acknowledge the
shortcoming of every single type of
research
rct is included right so if it happened
in a petri dish or a flu a fruit fly or
a mouse immediately you have to say well
let's wait and see yeah you know someone
will follow up with more data yeah and
that's fine it's okay to take a
wait-and-see approach
something
is an epidemiology finding you say okay
well that's interesting let's see if
this gets gets replicated uh
experimentally
someone comes out with a randomized
controlled trial and there's 12
participants per group
you say well that's an interesting
finding but am i necessarily certain
that those 12 people represent the
global population
or the population that is most relevant
to me yeah probably not right so
whatever layer of research you're
looking at there's going to be
limitations even
the renowned meta-analysis right so i
mentioned an analysis a meta-analysis
earlier where i said yeah the analysis
indicated 500 calories per day is a big
enough deficit to blunt your lean mass
gains but don't take it too literally
and the reason i say that is a
meta-analysis can only
calculate based on the data that exists
yeah and the data that exists are
dependent upon the conditions in which
they're collected
and so uh you might look for example
at a body of literature and find bias
that is built into the literature
and cannot be
untangled without more research right so
if you're looking at high versus low
protein intakes in a big meta regression
but you also notice
most of the high protein studies are
specifically in elderly folks and a lot
of the other studies are more likely to
be in younger folks now you've got age
and protein level kind of intermingled
and you can't parse those out without
additional stuff oh yeah you you
actually see this all the time in uh a
type of meta-analysis that i understand
why it exists but i personally don't
like it um so there's a certain genre of
meta-analysis where they essentially
take
just all of the studies that have
reported on a particular outcome and
then
uh and it's not necessarily studies
where like one group does x one group
does y and then like compare between the
two groups those those are my favorite
type types of metas but this type that
i'm talking about basically you just get
all of the studies that report on a
particular outcome and then you just
look to see kind of between studies
what study characteristics are
predictive of
better
or
of better results for the outcome of
interest um
and so like in in one of those that
comes to mind
i think it was just looking at like what
resistance training variables are
associated with lean mass gains and
female lifters i think that's what it
was um but one of the things that they
found was that
the length of the training intervention
was negatively associated with lean mass
gains in other words if you interpreted
that literally the longer someone trains
not the the less not
basically like it's not saying the rate
of gains slows down over time it's
saying the absolute gains are smaller
with longer training interventions so
you know if you interpreted that
literally like hey i trained for three
months and put on five kilos of muscle
mass and then over the next three years
i lose two kilos and and that's what i
should expect so over time i only gained
three kilos or or something like that um
but much like you're getting that
the the
the thing that was actually driving that
finding was that most of the really
long-term interventions were in elderly
subjects because
most of the studies in younger people is
it's college kids and so you're pretty
much limited by the length of a semester
and so those studies run
16 weeks if you're really on the ball
and you can get everyone in the lab on
day one typically you're limited to
about 12 weeks tops
and so like yeah a lot of those studies
people gained a fair a fair bit of lean
mass in studies on older subjects who
are maybe community dwelling and you can
run a resistance training study for two
years yeah they don't gain all that much
muscle but they're older
they're generally less active generally
less healthy and also just generally not
training very hard uh because because
they're super old and you're not putting
them on uh
a super super intense training program
so yeah i mean like that is a finding
you could come away from a particular
meta-analysis with like hey the longer
you train the less lean mass you gain
again not on a cumulative basis on an
absolute basis um or not on a
marginal basis i mean um
yeah like like
like you're saying you have to put that
in context of what what was this meta
actually doing and what were the studies
that went into it yeah and you know one
thing that people will push back when
you start talking about this whether
they're looking at
a meta-analysis meta regression or an
epidemiology paper is
you know there's a certain level of
insight where you're not familiar with
the research and you don't even think
about covariates
and then you learn more about research
and you start to embrace covariates and
you put too much confidence in what
they're actually doing so i've seen this
before where i say
yeah i'm not really excited about that
finding because of this that and the
other factor and someone says well no
but they controlled for that
and i go
well
they co-varied for it you know and
it's not necessarily the same thing you
know so when you start digging into some
of these models and this is especially
true in epidemiology
you have to start worrying about
multi-co-linearity
and the degree to which you truly can
untangle certain variables by just using
covariates and if if two factors are so
related that they represent the same
underlying thing
if you include one as a covariate what
is the actual impact that has on the
true predictor yeah and i know that this
is getting a little deep for podcast
content like this is kind of more the
thing you sketch out in an article so
you can give examples and things but
anyway all of that is i would say it
even goes a level deeper than that
even if there is just like
one covariate that that you know
matters and it's and you're not running
into multi-co-linearity issues with the
the variable of interest
uh
most modeling approaches still assume
that the the relationsh that the
covariate relationship is roughly linear
and so if it's not a linear relationship
like if it's a
curvilinear relationship of
some sort that's
something other than linear uh that in
and of itself can can introduce
um an additional level of error when
you're interested in the actual
relationship with the outcome of
interest yeah and so like even if
even if you pass all of the checks you
don't have multi-co-linearity issues you
know that the covariate is something
that should be included in your model
you don't always get that far by
including it in your model unless you
can do further tests and
you're really good at coding statistical
software to to assume that the
covariates relationship isn't a linear
relationship but most of the time
they're they're just
plugged in
with the assumption that it's linear
yeah and so we are
um looking over a ledge that that would
you know sometimes you start talking
about these things and people walk away
with the conclusion like oh so like we
don't know anything and never will like
this stuff starts to feel really
complicated and a little bit
overwhelming but it's actually a really
reassuring thing because
uh
we collectively understand this nuance
that goes into a body of research and so
there's nothing more frustrating than
when you are looking at a body of
research and something just doesn't work
things don't fit together and you're
like what is happening here how do i
work through this roadblock of
misunderstanding
and that's the beauty of it is that this
stuff is complicated such that if you
really
dig into it and start to unravel the
complexity you can say okay
i think i understanding why this finding
doesn't line up with that finding i
think i understand why this evidence
doesn't reflect what's being uh shown
from this evidence like
the complexity at first seems
overwhelming
and kind of makes you feel like we'll
screw this i'll do something else like i
don't i don't want anything to do with
all this complexity but it actually the
the complexity is
the
the opening for us to actually make
sense of
incomplete data and incomplete
understanding it allows us to dig deeper
and contextualize some of the things
that are really hard to understand on
the surface so so that's a really
positive thing but the the the moral of
the story is you got to make sure that
whenever you're looking at a research
finding it it's always
so that you are
you never want to lose sight of the full
body of evidence so don't just get
locked into the mechanistic basic
science and petri dishes don't just get
locked into the epidemiology put all of
it together basic science epidemiology
randomized controlled trials well-done
meta-analyses they all work together
and that's it's a really beautiful thing
when they come together and you say
this is the mechanism driving this
effect in experiments which is why we
see this observation at the population
level and this meta analysis quantifies
the relationship effectively like
that's when it all comes together and
it's a beautiful thing and then all the
arguments are
more or less done theoretically
hopefully yeah yeah one other thing i'll
just add just to kind of put a bow on
this discussion because i i assume we
probably need to move on is i think
broadly speaking um
there's i i think there are issues with
with science communication
um such that
in my conception at least there are
studies that are
that
i i think at least should almost
exclusively just be read and interpreted
by other scientists and then there are
studies that
other scientists should also read and
interpret but that are
essentially safe for public consumption
uh if you will
and i would largely put
most epi research
in the category of not safe for public
consumption not because there's anything
wrong with it but as you're alluding to
like different
types of studies have different purposes
and
epi research
more often than not
is is kind of like hypothesis generating
research where it's basically like what
trends do we see on a population level
uh what sorts uh like what magnitudes of
effects are we seeing
okay like we've now identified these
associations
and it's time to do some actual
experimental research to see if these
broader trends do actually pan out as
interventions and then if they do then
maybe that goes over to the public
health people and they can make some
recommendations blah blah blah
um
but yeah like i i think that
i i think that like a lot of and i would
say the same about animal research as
well like there are there's so many
animal studies they get a ton of
headlines that people just have no
business reading because like unless you
unless you spend a lot of time kind of
in science
it's get it's gonna be difficult to
interpret stuff in a way such that you
actually come to to useful conclusions
and you're not
like way over interpreting everything
and i ultimately don't blame the public
for this
and i really don't blame science
journalists all that much for it even
though i i do blame some of them a
little bit um
more than anything i i blame university
press departments for it because like
uh
this the stuff that gets out
that
major outlets pick up and write about
more often than not is the stuff that
university press departments push like
uh some researchers have some findings
that seem kind of splashy um
they're not necessarily expecting the
journalists to read every word of the
actual published research article
uh they kind of package the findings and
maybe like a couple little quotes from
the researchers
in a press package and just send it out
to a bunch of journalists to say like
hey
like do you want clicks in your uh in
your health section of your publication
well cool we've basically written an
article for you and now you just need to
change some paragraphs which it would be
great if that's not how
a lot of that industry functioned but
the way journalism works now like the
the expectations for the level of output
that
is expected of journalists tends to be
pretty ridiculous
and so like they're generally not going
to have time to dig super super deep
into each study they need to write about
for their publication and so basically
the university press departments just do
most of that work for him uh and then
kind of pre-package this story for him
and dude university press departments
don't need to be sending out press
releases for [ __ ] rodent studies or
for a lot of uh epidemiological studies
like i i think that
i think that ultimately that's the the
prime mover in this
information flow
i think that a lot of bad stuff comes of
it um
so yeah like i i
largely view that research as is more
just the stuff that scientists should
talk about amongst themselves and then
once you have
more applied experimental research in
human studies then let's get it out to
the public that's that that's the the
type of stuff that one is going to be
more relevant for people and two is just
more difficult to misinterpret
so
uh that's that's kind of my perspective
on it yeah and you know it's i think
sometimes people
underestimate the harm that comes from
the splashy headlines because i've
talked to people who really don't take
an interest in you know the this public
health science
at all
they just would like to live a long
healthy life if they can yeah and a lot
of times the result of these splashy
headlines that um
are not robust
is it leads a lot of people in the
general public to just kind of throw up
their hands and say yeah you're telling
me red wine is great but you told me
three months ago that it gives me cancer
so what am i supposed to do with this
you know and it can be a really
frustrating thing
and when you brought up this topic one
of the reasons i was like oh this is
gonna i'm gonna have a lot to say
uh when i was working on my phd i was in
a fellowship and there was an open
opportunity if you want to create a
course at this university from scratch
that is accessible to you you just got
to pitch the idea and i was like
really
like that that's a
quite
quite a lot of freedom to hand off to
students you know grad students but
anyway i got together with a group of
people and we made a course that was
explicitly on
interpretation and communication of
science and it was a really fun course
because it was me
who was doing randomized controlled
trials
uh great start i i just enjoyed how long
that pause was it was great because it
was me
all right
moving on yeah anyway what's next no
yeah our next segment we have a research
what i was getting at
i was doing rcts almost exclusively a
little bit of meta-analysis
and i partnered up with an
epidemiologist who taught a third of the
course and we also partnered up with a
physicist who did um
all of her research was simulations it
was like
i'm gonna write insanely complex code
hit go and a super computer is going to
chew on it for like two days like stuff
that i can't even begin
i don't know if she
if she could even explain to me a
general concept of what she studied like
the intelligence discrepancy was
enormous but anyway it was a really fun
dynamic because you know we can't just
go in there and say uh screw all the
basic science and and the theory and
screw all the epidemiology rcts are the
real science because like my colleagues
wouldn't let me get away with it right
and that's not a good take so it was a
nice combination of like
we represent all these different types
of science let's talk about the
strengths and the weaknesses the ways to
communicate
and so on and it was a great it was a
great course in my opinion but um
you know one of the things that i think
we
in hindsight we were young one of the
things that we me kind of whiffed on
was we didn't focus enough on what you
mentioned which is the university press
release
driving a lot of the
uh misinterpretations i i think if i
could do that course again i would have
been a little bit easier on the uh
health science journalist side of things
yeah and a little bit more harsh on the
university press release side of things
but that does kind of lead into one of
the questions i saw in the q a
thing
so i hope you don't mind if i jump ahead
here nah go for it but logan fitness
asked what's the advice or viewpoint
that you've shared over the years that
you most regret giving something that
you've done a total 180 on it and you're
now embarrassed for for having said it
out loud or kind of uh putting your name
on it so the reason i thought of this so
i was like you know if i could go back
and and redo some of those lectures
you know that's one of the areas we
could have improved it but i'm curious
to see how you would answer this
yeah so the the question itself at are
we just onto the q and a segment now all
right q a time um
so yeah one of the operative words i
think in this question was regret
what would you most regret
giving
and honestly i don't have a ton of
regrets uh as it relates to advice that
i've given people
largely because
to me
like i very much don't want to be wrong
but also
it doesn't bother me that much like i
try to avoid it to the greatest extent
possible but also
if you're
putting content out into the world and
doing the best job you can for long
enough you're going to be wrong from
time to time
and i think you need to have kind of
thick skin about that
and and not just let the mere fact that
you're wrong or that you have been wrong
keep you up at night you know you just
correct the record move on um
i think i think there's only much room
for regret
if advice that you've given uh is likely
to have tangibly calls to non-trivial
harm
and so i don't think any of the stuff
i've said has really caused harm
largely because i think when i had a
much larger proportion of bad ideas i
also had a much smaller audience and so
no matter what i told people like the
the the possibility of harm was very
constrained um
but the the one that i look back on i
fitness related at least and cringe the
most uh is is i did used to be a very
big keto guy just
fully drank the kool-aid um
and like in in my defense that was
before i had even completed my
bachelor's like i
i was very stupid um but yeah i was i
was like
all aboard the keto train for a while um
not the proudest moment of my life i
also used to really really drink the
west side kool-aid when it came to
training um and i wouldn't say i've
completely done a 180 on that but i have
moderated my views a little bit i used
to think west side is the best side like
that's
that's how that's how everyone has to
train if they want to
get super strong and freaky huge um and
like
now i think if anything the pendulum has
swung too far back the other way where
uh a lot of people are very down on west
side like it's it's not chic anymore i i
think basically now it's an effective
training method within an ocean of
effective training methods um you know
it's very fun works well for a lot of
people not all that special um
yeah those are
those are probably the two biggest
things
most directly related to the general
content of this podcast
um
again going back to the concept of
regret
and and whether spreading views may have
had
done harm or had serious negative
ramifications this is something that i
don't regret but that i do also
very much cringe when i think about so
if
occasionally when the topics may be
related to marijuana come up on this
podcast we play characters of uh being
very
conservative kind of like 1980s moral
majority members as a bit uh because of
how
ridiculous at least i find like the
anti-drug rhetoric that uh persists to
today
but uh
i did actually used to be a
very fundamentalist christian and young
earth creationist
and
that's how i was raised once i got old
enough to kind of look into things and
start thinking for myself a little more
i realized like oh yeah no no that's
that's not what i'm about uh but i i
still think back to
having conversations maybe related to
the age of the earth when i was like 12
13 and i'm like oh no greg what did you
do
what what do those people think about
you today
to be fair
wasn't it your mother that clipped that
segment from landing yes
so like you didn't get access to that
whole documentary as a kid
that is true um yeah so uh land before
time was one of my favorite movies and
like i would watch it maybe
probably more than once a week as like a
very small child
but the intro to the movie
i don't know exactly what it says
because it wasn't present in the copy of
the vhs i had but i think it says
something along the lines of 65 million
years ago blah blah blah the dinosaurs
and i only know it's it ends with the
dinosaurs because that's where the
version of the vhs i had picked back up
um yeah with a vhs tape
uh
our younger listeners may not understand
how that technology worked uh if the
first
video medium you remember was dvds but
vhs tapes like there's basically just
little frames that
uh like a light is shown through and
then it's kind of red and it's projected
uh onto your crt but there's ask your
grandparents yeah but but like each
frame contains an image on it and so
like you can you you could manually edit
them by just opening it up
pulling the tape out
finding the the set of frames that
corresponded with material that you
didn't want to expose people to
and then literally just cut it and like
suture it back together yeah i mean
earlier i used the term on the cutting
room floor yeah yeah exactly where it
comes from yeah yeah that's that's how
that's how film used to be edited but
you know with that that would be like
big film correct but same idea yeah you
could doctor a vhs tape the exact same
way and that's that's what my mom did to
our copy of land before time any mention
of
the earth being more than six thousand
years old had been excised from the cop
and so like you said if i would have
been exposed to the entirety of that
documentary evidence um maybe i would
have changed my mind sooner but yeah
oh man that's that's awesome
yeah for me um
like i said like i can go back and i've
been
given talks and teaching and you can go
back to a lecture and say like oh yeah i
used to think things about like uh
plant-based protein sources that i would
revise or i used to say things about
acute muscle protein synthesis findings
that really
overextend
inappropriate interpretation of them but
i do i wouldn't say i regret it because
it was
doing my best with what i had you know
some of that evidence has really changed
a lot since i would say those things and
ultimately i've always tried to hedge my
bets in the direction of non-harm right
so like uh i've never been one to say
you know what let's try something crazy
with nutrition you know like i i don't
have a lot of good evidence but let's go
for it um but yeah i think your your
um
perspective is is a healthy one which is
like hey
did my best with what i had
uh tried to help people didn't do
anything too out of line and you know
that's that's really the only way to do
it like if you
were just absolutely terrified of saying
something that was five percent wrong
it'd be really hard to make content you
know yeah for sure um
so did you have any other
q a stuff that you wanted to cover we
are
a minute or an hour 15 in here
to wrap it up i i'd be very cool with
that that's that's less prep work for
the next episode
uh one thing i did want to mention here
before we close out so i've been trying
to be more um
attentive to when i say things
that might seem divisive uh without
appropriate context like
i'll say something and the context in my
mind isn't divisive but the way it comes
out sounds divisive so you know we kind
of had some chuckles at the expense of
like the carnivore diet and the keto
diet
and you know it i just wanted to clarify
like if you enjoy consuming a diet like
that that doesn't bother me i don't
think you're a dumb person i i don't uh
like i don't lose sleep over that and i
certainly wouldn't want to disparage an
individual who gravitates toward those
options like i think it's really hard
i cannot think of a context where i
would call a carnivore diet a
an optimal approach to nutrition and i
can think of a lot of ways it can go
wrong
um so like i'm not a big fan of it but i
don't consider that to be a a personal
flaw and i don't like poke fun at people
who
are
uh
you know maybe getting some information
about those diets that isn't reliable
and isn't solid and with keto
you know there are ways to do a keto
diet that is completely feasible and and
not um not an issue whatsoever yeah just
just to clarify that further because
that that that is a good point um yeah
there's
a lot of very defensible ways to set up
a ketogenic diet um i think what i
regret more than anything uh is i had
fully bought an into the carbohydrate
insulin model yeah of uh
obesity weight gain whatever um and
that i think is completely
scientifically bankrupt uh so that that
is what i
regret more than merely recommending
ketogenic diets yeah the thing for me is
the the hype right so like you know i i
currently consume a vegetarian diet but
at the same time when game changers came
out i was like hey guys we can just say
like hey here's an option we don't have
to go like way overboard with the claims
and and kind of get ridiculous with it
yeah and i was in the same place as you
where there was a time between like 2012
and 2014
when
if you if you had your finger on the
pulse of the research
but hadn't really built the skills to
truly dive into it you would have
thought due to the trajectory of the way
research was going that the ketogenic
diet was
magic like that there was something
profoundly special
that makes it optimal in a variety of
conditions and and that was uh
a version of kool-aid that a lot of
people got swept up in
um so yeah it's not about saying like oh
man the idea of entertaining a ketogenic
diet is so dumb but getting caught up in
the hype like i think a lot of people
were there oh yeah and myself included i
was very intrigued by it and in
hindsight you say
damn it
yeah wish i could have that perspective
back
um
but anyway
wrapping up the show here uh to play us
out we did not forget about the feats of
strength we've got a
a special one here and greg since this
is your territory i will let you take
over
yeah so uh it finally happened
i think
the 800 pound bench press barrier
appears to have been broken
daniel zamani uh
posted a training video of himself binge
pressing 365 kilos which is about 805
pounds
uh
and
so just just for
just to rewind a bit we've talked about
this guy before on the podcast i've
previously expressed some skepticism and
trepidation regarding whether his lifts
are in fact legit or not um
that
trepidation hasn't gone away entirely
but i the more the more i see of this
guy the more
legit i think his lifts are uh and you
can watch this video for yourself it'll
be embedded in the shown or it'll be
linked in the show notes um
the bar behaves as if there's an
enormous amount of weight on it and if
you just look at the guy he looks like a
guy who would bench press
an outrageous amount of weight
so i do
stand by my statement that i want to see
him
compete in a meet with weights that we
know to be calibrated and the
appropriate weights um
you know there is always the possibility
when all you're seeing is gym lifts that
people are posting on social media
maybe something isn't above board but i
i i personally
used to be far more skeptical than i am
now i do still retain some degree of
skepticism um i would still love to see
him compete
but i
think that this video that you can see
by clicking on it in the show notes i do
think that that it's the the first 800
pound bench press which we all thought
that julius maddox was gonna do but
zamani just came out of nowhere
[ __ ] monster and
uh just just hitting insane numbers um
and
i don't know man like watching this lift
it
it makes me think back to kind of like
the the history of the bench press and
power lifting
because like the first equipped 800
pound bench press didn't fall all that
long ago um
you have like 30 seconds of input so i
can just really quick google when the
first 800 pound equip bench pressure
yeah yeah um
no i mean looking at this video uh like
you said it initially you weren't the
you weren't just like some rogue actor
saying i call bs on these lifts i mean
there are a lot of people in the
comments as he was posting videos into
the mid and high 700s saying i don't
know are we sure about this
but yeah you look at this video of him
benching 804 the way the bar is moving
looks like it's got at least 803 pounds
yeah like i i'm i'm definitely a
believer and i think a lot of people are
coming around to that perspective
yeah so the the first 800 pound equipped
binge press was tim isaac in 1999
which
isn't that it isn't all that long ago um
and so
i don't know it's this is this is making
my head spin like 700
seemed to be the final frontier for the
bench press at least in terms of 100
pound barriers
and then when julius maddox started
chipping away at it pushing it up into
760 770 it's like oh [ __ ] 800 is gonna
happen
but then
i don't know there's a part of me deep
within my soul that wants to say we have
seen the final hundred pound barrier
fall for the raw bench press
but like i don't know man who's to say
uh
will will 900 ever happen or is this the
final frontier like with with the mile
for example when a sub four minute mile
happened
you knew that that was the last minute
barrier just like due to
certain
constraints within human physiology um
unless just like track surfaces and the
equipment allowed changes dramatically
we're never going to see a sub 3 mile
but
like and same thing with the marathon
it's like sub two is it yeah we're we're
not gonna see a sub one marathon yeah
it's ridiculous
but yeah with
with the bench press i don't i don't
know what those physiological
constraints are so
uh every time a new barrier is broken
that allows us to see a little bit
further beyond the horizon to say like
well
you know before it was in question like
was this
barrier possible to break well now we
know that it is
how about the next one we really don't
know um so yeah i i
very much hope that this lift is real
and like i said at this
at this moment i do think that it is
um
and yeah it makes me really excited
because another big milestone has been
shattered and and i'm excited to see
what'll come next
i'm excited to see him
and julius maddox go toe-to-toe yeah i
think that would be such a fun event if
they can logistically pull it off yeah
uh the the meat that they were supposed
to do like the the reason zamani hit
this 800 in the gym is he was planning
on hitting it
at the meet that was planned that i
think
was supposed to have either been this
past weekend or this upcoming weekend um
it ended up getting canceled
or like ended up just not happening
because uh julius maddox i think got a
shoulder injury
um and had to pull out
so yeah the the
actual competition status of all of this
is still kind of up in the air i i do
want to see this number done in a meet
but
you know under the assumption that these
gym weights weigh the same as comp
weights like weights weight uh
i ultimately don't care where a lift
happens as long as as long as the weight
moves like it's a good lift in my book
um
yeah man
you should watch the video it's
it's insane he's
he's so freaky strong and just when he
when he re-racks the weight
just
just watching the bar
like
so i do
i previously have done a fair bit of
heavy rack pulls back when i respected
gym equipment a little bit less like if
i'm going to go heavy now it's going to
be block pulls but i used to do some
very heavy pretty disrespectful rack
pulls and
the way
that the bar flexes
when he re-racks it for a [ __ ] bench
press looked the same way
as like you know you're doing seven
eight hundred pound rock rack pulls and
just sit the bar down really hard on the
rack like the same level
of oscillation which which is the thing
that's that sells me on it like
i don't know i think that
suspect plates are a lot easier to pull
off than like an extra whippy bar
um like i said
you you would need to go to considerable
lengths to pull off that sort of fraud i
think so yeah i i think it's real and
i want to see it in a meet yeah good
stuff all right so that does it for this
episode of the stronger by science
podcast as always thank you for joining
us and we will be back in one week
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you